[تصفيق]
انا اسمي محمد هشام محرم باختصار كده
خلوني احكيلكم ال قصه يعني ازاي الموضوع ج
بدا معايا ان انا بكتب في الكوره خلينا
نرجع من وانا في اعدادي انا كنت في اعدادي
الطالب الكويس اللي بيحب يذاكر والمدرسين
بيحبه ويحب يجيب درجات
عاليه بس دايما كان عندي مشكله ان انا كان
انا بحب بقى اقفل المواد وبتاع بس ما كنتش
بعرف اجيب دايما درجه عاليه في العربي
عشان كانوا بيقولوا انا عندي مشكله في
التعبير
عشان ما بلتزم بالمقدمه وبالختم
عدت فتره اعدادي اللي هي فيها انا كنت
طالب الكويس وبعد كده دخلت في مرحله ثانوي
واللي كان هنا في مدرسه ثانوي حكومه هيعرف
ان فتره المدرسه بتاع الصبح اللي هي من يه
لاثنين دي كانت هي فتره الصبحه فتره
الفسحه في الثانويه العامه
لان انت ب غير كده يا اما بدرس يا اما
بتذاكر يا اما عامل بتذاكر قدام
اهلك اشتغلت كتير اشتغلت في سايبر واشتغلت
في مطاعم واشتغلت في مصنع شنط وكفرات
وحاجات من
كده وذاكرت في الثانويه العامه جبت
السنتين على بعض 92 في وكان قدامي كذا
اوبشن كان قدامي ان انا اخش انجلش او اخش
اداب او اخش ريشات سياحي فانا اخترت اداب
واخترت قسم لغه
اسبانيه يعني هو انا بتكسف اقول انا دخلت
ليه اللغه اسبانيه بس هو عشان انا كنت
سمعت اغنيه انطوني بنديس وحبيتها فدخلت
القسم يعني هي فعلا جت كده فكنت داخل بحب
الاسباني داخل بحب الاسباني وحابب اللغه
وحابب
اتعلمها بس القدر يعني وقع في سكتي رئيسه
القسم مش كرهتني في الاسباني يعني بصراحه
هي كرهتني في حياتي كلها ف وانا قريت كنت
بحب الشغل اكتر من دراسه
فالدراسات
كده نجحت في سنه اولى مش عارف نجحت ازاي
بصراحه لان انا كنت بقول للناس طب يا
جماعه اللغه سهله قالوا لي اه قلت لهم طب
قولو لي مثلا اي حاجه بالاسباني يوم السبت
مثلا يعني ايه فقالوا لي يعني سبد فانا
قلت بس خلاص دي اللغه سهله سبد احد وثنين
وثلاثه وخلاص مشيت كده طلع بقى لا خدعوني
اللغه مش كده جت سنه اولى وطلعت سنه تانيه
سب احده ما جابتش معاهم خالص بقى سقت في
سنه تانيه ا وسقت في سنه انيه تاني بصراحه
ونجحت ثالث سنه في سنه
تانيه ثالث سنه في سنه تانيه وبعد كده
طلعت ثالثه قررت ان انا هوقف شغل لان انا
محتاج اتخرج
لان خلاص بقى ضيعت من عمري كفايه يعني
وعايز اتخرج فوقفت شغل بس سنه الثالثه
كانت سنه الثوره ا الثوره غيرت فيا كتير
يعني انا قبل الثوره حد وبعد الثوره حد
الثوره غيرت مفاهيم وقواعد وغيرت ثوابت
وكل حاجه يعني فجي الخناقه بقى اللي هي
بعد الثوره بتاع دوله دينيه لا دوله
علمانيه فكنت حابب اقول للناس ان ان مش
وقته ان لسه في حاجات اهم من
كده وانا مش الشخص اللي ممكن الميدان
والناس تتلمى حواليه وهو يتكلم ويقول لهم
كذا وكذا فكانت اقرب حاجه الكتابه كنت
عايز اكتب فكتبت حاجه اسمها عود ثوار حتى
تعود و ونشرتها على
الفيسبوك وانتشرت كويس وعملتلها برينت
وبقيت بوزع في المترو وفي الميدان الناس
اللي حواليا طيب تمام انت بتكتب كويس جرب
تكتب تاني وبتاع عملت بلوج في هوه
البلوجرز اللي عملوا في مصر كلها وبدات
اكتب وقعدت يمكن سنه بكتب بس خلاص بقى
وكتبت في مواقع يعني بس بقى كنت عايز احس
ان انا صحفي يعني كنت خلاص من الوقت ده
الاسباني مش هو شغلتي ان انا هشتغل حاجه
لها علاقه بالكلام اوردي كنت شغال ماركتنج
قبل كده فقلت خلاص انا هخلص ماركتين
يعني ا بدات كتابه ورحت كذا جريده رحت
الاول جريده تابعه لجريده
قوميه قالوا لي يعني كلامك كويس بس مش
هنقدر
ننشره عشان يعني انا كنت بكتب حاجات هم ما
كانوش بيحبوها مش متوافقين معاها يعني
سياسيا يعني كنت بكتب في السياسه الاول
وبعدين رحت جري
الجريده الخاصه عاملين تحت الجريده زي
جراج
كده في 50 60 واحد زي حلاتي
بيكتبه بينزل رئيس التحرير بالليل يعدي
يشوف المقال اللي عاجبه وخبرته كده يحطله
الخبره يعني وينشره باسمه صحفي 50 60 جنيه
حاجه
كده فان ماحبتش ا ده لان حسيت ماشي انا
شاب وعايز فلوس وكل حاجه عايز اعمل اسمي
الاول يعني فرجعت البيت بمنتهى البؤس اللي
في الدنيا وسكر داون بمنتهى البؤس
برض ك بتفرج على ماتش كوره وبشوف بقى
الاخبار يعني بعد الماتش مين اص حصله ايه
فلقيت سايت اسمه كور لاين طالب
محررين منع وابعت اسم فان الس بتاعي كان
هو اصلا عباره عن اسمي كتش عملت اي حاجه
فبعتت اسمي فيسبوك بتاعي وبعديها يمكن
باسبوعين ونزلت تريني وبقيت بترجم الاخبار
من اسباني لعربي ده نفعني يعني شويه
الاسباني اللي انا اخدتهم من الكليه كده
نفعي عشان ما كانش موجود كتير حد بيترجم
الاسباني العربي كانوا بيترجم يعني
بيستنوا حد يترجم من اسباني لانجلش وبعد
كده هم يترجموا من انجلش
لعربي ف في اول لاث شهور بقيت رئيس قسم
الكره الاسبانيه في
كورلاين وبعدين على اخر السنه بقيت نائب
رئيس تحرير السايت
ا كان ليه حد شغال معايا في السايت هو كان
رئيس التحرير يعني ساعتها قال لي اعمل
صفحه باسمك اكتب فيها لان انا كنت كتبت
مقال عن الكوره بطريقه ادبيه اللي هي كنت
بكتب بيها في السياسه قبل كده يعني كنت
مشبه لعيب بباتمان وكنت يعني كان مقال
ادبي يعني ا فانا عملت الصفحه برض بخوف
لان هي اسمها مقالات محمد هشام
محرم ف فالموضوع اللي هو انا لو فشلت فهو
الاسم اه الصفحه فانا لو فشلت الفشل
هيرتبط باسمي طول
عمري عملت الصفحه وبدات اكتب بالاسلوب
اللي انا عايز اكتب بيه ا وحسيت بعد كده
ان الوقت اللي انا باخده في ترجمه الاخبار
لا انا عايز استغله في ان انا ابقى كاتب
لان انا عايز ابقى كاتب مش عايز ابقى محرر
ا بدات اقرا اكتر وبدات
ا ادخل الكوره في في الادب بطريقه ثانيه
بطريقه طب انا اول هشوف اللي انا اتعلمته
ايه وهط بقه عن الكوره فبدات مثلا اتكلم
مثلا
عن ان حد كان بيهاجم طول الماتش وما جابش
جوان فشبهت بدونك خوطي اللي هو كان بيحارب
طواحين الهواء
ا لحد كاس العالم 2014 كانت
الصفحه كان بقى بقسه جدا كان فيها 200 بني
ادم انا عامل 199 واحد فيهم انفايت وفي
واحد كده ماعرفش ج منين يعني
بعد كاس العالم بدات برض اكتب اح الكوره
بعيدا عن 4 وال المعروفه يعني حل برض
بطريقه
ادبيه لحد ما لقيت حد زي خالد بيومي ب
الصفحه خالد بيومي اظم محلل الكره مصري
يعني وشفاء مراد بين سبور برض بتشير
الصفحه الموضوع بدا يبقى مخيف بقى في
اسامي استمريت في
ده
وبدات بقى اكتب في الجوانب الحياتيه يعني
يعني الكوره فيها
قص كتير بعيدا عن عن ان هي زي ما الناس
بتقول جلده مدوره والناس بتجري وراها يعني
الكوره مش مش اقل جمالا من اي حاجه ان هي
تتوصف بالادب يعني يعني مثلا من القصص
اللي اثرت فيا شخصيا قصه
ماردو ديجو ارماندو
مارادونا راح نابولي ونابولي على الهبوط
نابولي فريق في ايطاليا كان راح نابولي
ونابولي قربت
تهبط اول يوم ليه في نابولي قالوا له قال
الجماهير ايه المطلوب مني قالوا له اسكوتو
اللي هو الدوري الايطالي وتغلب
يوفنتوس السنه اللي بعديها نابولي كان في
منتصف
الجدول وبعديها بحوالي سنه او سنتين
نابولي خدت الدوري نابولي خدت الدوري بفضل
مارادونا لحد النهارده رقم 10 ده مافيش اي
لعيب في نابولي بيلبسه لان ده بتاع
مارادونا بس يعني كل سنه رقم 10 بيطبع
عليه اسمه
مارادونا لحد النهارده انتوا عارفين
نابولي في الجنوب في ايطاليا فمعظمها
عصابات
ومافيا لحد النهارده ممنوع حد ارجنتيني
يتسرق تكريما لمارادونا
الجماهير بتاعه نابولي مجانين لدرجه ان هم
بعد ما كسبوا الدوري راحوا بيفط على
المقابر بتاعه الموت موتاهم بيقولوا اه لو
تعلمون ما فتكم بيعايروا الميكين ان هم ما
شافوش مارادونا وهو بياخد
الدوري وبعدين في قصه اجمل قصه روبرتو
باجيو روبرتو باجيو كان لاعب في فيورنتينا
الايطالي واتباع غصب عنه لان النادي كان
في ضائقه ماليه ومضطر ان هو يبيع افضل
لاعب عنده هو روبرتو باجيو فالنادي اتباع
فالنادي باعه ليوفنتوس
يوفنتوس وفيورنتينا في بينهم خلاف تاريخ
كبير
يعني بعد ما باعوا كان اول ماتش لجيو ضد
فريقه القديم الجماهير فضلت تشتمه عشان هو
ساب
الفريق وج ضربه جزاء لفريقه الجديد وهو
رافضها عشان هو يعني مش هيجيب في فريق
فالمدرب طلعه كان العقاب وهم طلعوا
الجماهير فضلت تشتمه وراموا عليه اللي هو
في ايده دهك بتاعنا فريقه القديم فهو كان
بيعيط وباس سكارف ولبسه على تيشيرت بتاع
يول الجديد يوفنتوس
ومشي بفتكر ان كان في حد لابس تيشرت باجيو
ويستم يعني هم بيحبوه لدرجه ان هم بيشتموه
في بقى اغرب حاجه قابلتني خالص كان ده مش
عمري
ديب ده خوليو ده كان حارس مرم ريال مدريد
للشباب وعمل حادثه والدكاتره قاله ان هو
هيقعد سنتين مش هيمشي على رجله
الممرض اللي كان معاه خليو سايب عليه فجاب
لله جيتار وقاله تعلم تعزف جيتار فتعلم ي
الجيتار وبدا يكتب كلمات
اغاني وبعد ما خف قرر ان هو هيشتغل في في
الطرب هيغني يعني عشان يساعد والده اللي
هو كان خد اجازه وقعد جنبه طول فتره
السنتين اللي كانت رجله وجعاه
فيها بدا يغني وبدا يروح بارات في امريكا
يغني فيها
بعت لشركه انتاج يقوللهم انا عندي كلمات
عايز حد يغنيها حد يغنيها وسجل وبعتها
لشركه الانتاج شركه الانتاج ردت عليه
قالتله طب ليه انت ما تغنيها قاللهم عشان
انا مش مغني قال وفعلا يه السجل ونجحت
وعمل البوم
ونجح وكسر الدنيا
الناس تعرف ان هو ليب كوره في الاصل
اللي عايز اقوله انا اسف ان انا
طولت ان ان في خط مرسوم لنا من يوم ما
اتولدنا خط بيقوللك انك المفروض تتولد في
مكان انت مخترتوش
تشتغل تتعلم تعليم انت برض ما اخترتو وفي
الغالب بتشتغل شغلانه انت اللي
لقيتها عشان لازم تشتغل وتيجي تحوش تحوش
تحوش تحوش وترمي كل الفلوس اللي انت
حوشتها دي تحت رجلين الخط المستقيم اللي
الناس شايفاه خط مستقيم مع ان استقامه
الخط دي ما بتعني اي حاجه غير ان القلب
توقف ان القلب مش شغال ما تنيش غير ان هي
موت يوم هتلاقي الخط ده بيتعود على وشك
وبتحول تعيد وشعرك ابيض وانت ما عملتش اي
حاجه في حياتك هتلاقي نفسك حاطط التودو
ليست بتاعتك في كتاب قديم مطرب انت حتى مش
فاكر اسمه وما علمتش صح على و انت
عايزها اختار
طريقك مش اللي حد تاني يختاره لك انا خريج
كليه اداب اسباني انا قعدت سبع سنين اي
نعم بس انا خريج كليه اداب
اسباني وقررت ان انا اشتغل صحفي فاشتغلت
صحفي انا من السيده زينب انا من حته شعبيه
جدا في القاهره
ا الكوره وحلمي خلاني ان انا بعد ما كنت
من كم سنه طفل صغير في السيده زينب بنزل
العب بلاي
ستيشن والعب بروبرت كارلوس خلاني
اعمل حوار مع كارلوس في يوم من
الايام احلى حاجه في النجاح نظره الناس
اللي كانت بتقوللك انت مش هتبقى الناس
اللي هي كانت لما يبقى في بروجكت في
الجامعه ياخدوا جنب منك كده عشان انت اصلا
من وجهه نظرهم انت تتوقعهم انت مش
هزو النجاح حلو بس في الحاجه اللي انت
بتحبها انا ممكن انجح في اي حاجه تانيه بس
انا ما بحبهاش ومش هكمل فيها النجاح حلو
في الحاجه بس اللي انت
بتحبها اشتغلوا واصرفوا واصرفوا على حلمكم
مش على الخط مش مش الناس بتقول لكم اصرفوا
عليه اشتغلوا وبسطوا وصرفوا عشان
المليونير المليونير هو اللي صرف المليون
مش اللي حوشهم
شكرا